after continued israeli strikes on gaza
and persistent pressure from his fellow
democrats president biden
is now calling for a ceasefire in a
phone call with israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu the white house says
in a statement
the president expressed his support for
a ceasefire
democratic congresswoman ilhan omar one
of the most persistent critics of the
president from within his own party
tweeted finally our delay in supporting
a ceasefire has caused the slaughter of
children
and destruction of lives now biden has
to push for an
end to the occupation the white house
press secretary has been insisting the
biden administration is engaged in quiet
diplomacy to end the conflict and reduce
palestinian and israeli casualties the
prism we are making all of our decisions
through
is how can we help bring an end to the
violence and bring an
end to de-escalate the situation on the
ground
in march president biden's own secretary
of state promised to make human rights
the foundation of american foreign
policy
and the biden terrorist administration
will stand against human rights abuses
wherever they occur regardless of
whether the perpetrators are adversaries
or partners critics argue the rights of
palestinians who make up the
overwhelming number of civilian deaths
and injuries in the current conflict
are being ignored and biden has failed
to roll back most of his predecessors
pro-israel policies that he once called
destructive
the u.s embassy remains in jerusalem
biden has not overturned president
trump's recognition of israel's
sovereignty over the occupied golan
heights
biden's foreign policy has also avoided
condemning forced expulsions of
palestinians from their homes
so far it is a it's a dramatic failure
the main reason for that is that the
administration was taken off
by surprise they did not expect this to
happen
it's partly a self-inflicted wound biden
maintains both israelis and palestinians
are entitled to safety and security in
equal measure
that's why some members of congress are
questioning reports of a recent
one-sided arms deal
735 million dollars in new weapons to
israel
some lawmakers argue the sale should be
halted until israel stops its military
campaign
biden has consistently defended israel's
right to defend itself and he has
repeatedly criticized the hamas rockets
raining down on israeli soil
at one point saying the israeli assault
was not disproportionate
but there have been days of air attacks
since then
now israelis and palestinians alike wait
to see if the american president's call
for a ceasefire will actually make a
difference
john hendren al jazeera washington